welcome to comic-con i am peter rubin
senior editor at Wired joined by our
special comic-con reporter Cara Santa
Maria and the end of the first day of
comic-con has finally drawn to a close I
went to the floor kind of right after it
opened and I wanted to do some sort of
man on the street interviews so I talked
to a lot of different cosplayers because
what's more exciting at comic-con it's
the heart and soul of the whole show it
really is I mean people work for months
sometimes years on their costumes either
collecting bits and pieces or making it
themselves I saw so many really
interesting kind of themed out groups
where everyone who came to comic-con
together with cosplaying together which
was super fun and yeah kind of amazing
stuff out there so I was here yesterday
when they unveiled this amazing wired
robot yes and Savage was kind of
introducing us to him he had never seen
it before he was blown away when it came
out from behind it I hadn't seen it
before they took that curtain away it's
pretty cool and so today the robot
actually kind of opened up the floor at
Comic Con yeah so we took we took the
robot to the show floor this is a 9 foot
9 inch cyan't MEK the problem was take a
giant mech to the show floor and it
becomes a fire hazard
not because he's hurting people but
because he draws a crowd it was like
like a really really really big like a
big like whoo concert in the 70s so they
had to ask the the giant mech to leave
so we beat a hasty retreat and and and
came back but he's he's around he's
stomping through the streets of San
Diego so if you're lucky enough to see
him I know we've got a hashtag and you
can tweet about wired mech so get on
that so you know there were also it
wasn't just all about the show floor and
the celebrities that came through wired
cafe what we also had tonight was the
first look at footage from Terry
Gilliam's new movie zero theorem which
stars the wonderful tarantino muse
christophe vaults with a shaved head
playing a crazy reclusive computer guy
who looks like it's gonna be a surreal
as every other terry gilliam movie is
but all to the good what were some of
the most conversations you had today I
was gonna say I could complain about you
being out on the floor doing all this
cool stuff while I was stuck in this
room but I was stuck in this room with
some pretty cool people so I got to
interview Bill Paxton about his new
graphic novel that he has
supercool guy from Texas where I'm from
we got to bond over barbecue a little
bit I also interviewed Kit Harington and
ladies love cool kid I know Johnny so
nobody help myself right taken aback by
his charm did he have that is the
British accent I think that did me is
the torture gaze to me and then after
that I got to interview slash I mean
come on we bonded over dinosaurs who
knew he was such a dinosaur nerd I know
we've got a ton more coming up for the
next three more days of this already
three more days we're a day and a half
in and we are just getting started
so we're gonna be back every day to wrap
up what we did you know that day so
we'll see you on day two for Cara Santa
Maria
Peter Ruben for Wired join us back here
at Wired Cafe comic-con